Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir, bonsoir à tous.
Les retraités parmi vous savent
les risques
que prennent les retraités
quand ils sortent de leur retraite.
En fait, par rapport
à la présentation précédente,
j'ai l'impression de ne pas avoir pris
beaucoup de risques avec ma profession.
En revanche, les objets de mon étude,
de mes études,
sont des objets à risque :
il s'agit des virus.
Les virus, tout le monde les connaît
plus ou moins par expérience,
expérience souvent malheureuse,
ce sont des micro-organismes
qui provoquent des maladies :
la rougeole, la grippe, le SIDA...
Et pour faire face à ces menaces,
il faut comprendre comment ça fonctionne.
Et c'est ce que je me propose
de faire, en partie.
Le virus est un organisme
biologique très simple.
Il est minuscule et pour entrer
dans le monde des virus,
je vous propose de le faire
par le critère de la taille.
On commence par des objets
visibles à l'œil nu,
comme un grain de café, un grain de riz,
une larve de farine séchée,
qu'on vient de voir tout à l'heure.
Et ça, c'est de l'ordre du centimètre
ou de quelques millimètres.
On passe ensuite
dans le monde des cellules,
ces cellules qu'on mesure
en millionième de mètre.
10 à 100 millionièmes de mètre.
Vous voyez ici une cellule de la peau,
pensez-y, elle va revenir.
On passe ensuite
dans le monde des bactéries.
Les bactéries sont des micro-organismes
dont la taille se mesure en micromètres,
en millièmes de mètre, micromètres.
Et puis on arrive dans le monde des virus,
qui se mesurent en milliardièmes de mètre,
une centaine de milliardièmes de mètre,
qu'on appelle nanomètres.
Allons une étape plus loin pour arriver
dans le monde des molécules.
Les molécules se mesurent en nanomètres,
milliardièmes de mètre.
Et dans ce monde, eh bien on trouve
des acides nucléiques, des protéines.
Et c'est bien parce que voilà
les constituants du virus.
Un virus, c'est un acide nucléique,
un génome au centre,
entouré par des protéines.
Voilà le virus.
Bien sûr, il n'est pas visible à l’œil nu,
mais par microscopie électronique,
on peut le mettre en évidence :
une couronne de protéines et un centre
avec le génome invisible.
On peut le représenter,
après reconstruction moléculaire,
et vous avez ici
la couronne de protéines :
il y en a trois différentes,
coloriées différemment,
et si on coupe en deux cette sphère,
il y a un vide à l'intérieur
où le génome est placé.
Ce génome a la propriété
d'être très, très petit
à l'échelle de la taille des virus.
Si un génome d'une cellule humaine
comporte plus de 3 milliards de lettres,
un génome d'un virus contient
entre 5 000 et 20 000 lettres.
Donc, très, très petit.
Pourtant ce génome contient
toute l'information nécessaire
à reproduire des virus.
Et les virus se multiplient
de la façon suivante :
un virus doit impérativement
entrer dans une cellule,
et quand on dit ça, on dit que le virus
dépose son génome dans la cellule,
et là, c'est à la cellule ensuite
de prendre en charge l'information
contenue dans ce génome
pour synthétiser
tous les constituants viraux
à de multiples exemplaires
pour que, après assemblage,
il y ait des particules virales
qui soient produites par milliers.
Un virus entre,
des milliers de virus sortent
voilà la multiplication virale.
Et ceci en l'espace de quelques heures.
Ce qu'il faut retenir
jusqu'à maintenant de ce que j'ai dit,
c'est que les virus
dépendent absolument de cellules
pour leur multiplication.
Mais les virus n'ont aucun moyen
de conformer les cellules
qu'ils ont à disposition.
Ils doivent faire avec les cellules
qu'ils rencontrent.
Et donc une des propriétés
que le virus a développées -
pensez virus - c'est la suivante :
si on ne peut pas adapter
le milieu dans lequel on se multiplie,
autant pouvoir s'adapter à ce milieu.
Et adaptation devient le mot-clé
de la survie ou la caractéristique-clé
de la survie du virus.
Mais comment cette adaptation
est-elle mise en œuvre ?
Cette adaptation est mise en œuvre
de la manière suivante :
soit un génome ;
ce génome, on peut même dire
qu'il a 10 000 lettres.
Ce génome est copié
autant de fois qu'il faut
pour générer la multitude de génomes
qui vont entrer
dans la multitude de virus.
Mais cette multiplication
ne se fait pas exactement comme décrit,
mais plutôt de la façon suivante,
à savoir qu'à partir de ce génome,
les copies qui sont issues
de la copie du génome entrant
sont toutes différentes,
ont la probabilité d'être différentes,
au moins d'une façon du génome
qui est la matrice pour la copie.
Et la probabilité
que ce changement a été introduit
est de l'ordre de 1 sur 10 000,
et c'est une propriété virale.
Donc pour un génome de 10 000 lettres,
avec une probabilité d'introduire
une erreur à 1 sur 10 000,
on voit que les génomes
qui sont produits par multiplication
ont tous la probabilité
de différer l'un de l'autre.
Si bien que, à la fin,
la multiplication virale
se présente plutôt de cette façon
où il y a des virus qui ressemblent
étrangement au virus entrant
mais en plus des virus,
des virus qui diffèrent,
dont le génome diffère tant soit peu
de l'un de l'autre et du virus entrant.
Donc une population hétérogène.
Les différentes tailles de ces virus
ne figurent pas une différence
de taille réelle des virus produits,
mais une différence de représentation
dans la population.
Donc il y a une population majoritaire
qui contient le génome du virus entrant,
entrant dans les conditions à disposition,
et une multitude de virus
qui ont tous acquis une mutation
et dans lequel les solutions
pour des changements de conditions
peuvent être trouvées.
On va illustrer ces caractéristiques
par deux exemples :
soit le virus HIV.
Vous connaissez tous le fait
que le virus HIV
se multipliant dans l'hôte,
l'hôte, sans traitement, invariablement,
est conduit à la mort.
Bien sûr et fort heureusement,
la recherche a trouvé des médicaments,
des médicaments qui ciblent
une fonction virale
de telle façon que c'est en présence
de ce médicament
qui représente pour le virus
un changement de conditions,
la population virale
est dans sa grande majorité
inhibée dans sa multiplication.
Pourtant, dans la population virale
existe un variant
qui a la propriété d'échapper
au blocage donné par le médicament.
Et ce variant devient la population
majoritaire et continue l'infection.
Quelle solution
a été trouvée à ce problème ?
La suivante : au lieu de traiter
avec un médicament,
on va traiter
avec trois médicaments différents
qui agissent sur trois cibles
différentes du virus.
Et dans cette situation,
la multiplication virale,
non seulement de l'espèce majoritaire
la mieux adaptée à ses conditions
mais la population hétérogène de mutants
qui auraient pu échapper à cette action,
tout est inhibé.
Quelle est l'explication ?
Si on considère
qu'une mutation est introduite
à une fréquence de 1 sur 10 000,
deux mutations dans le même génome
vont être introduites à une fréquence
de 1 sur 10 000 fois 1 sur 10 000.
Et trois mutations
à 1 sur mille milliards.
Même si le virus se multiplie
des milliards de fois,
la probabilité que cette situation arrive
est tellement faible
que le virus est inhibé
et que la personne infectée
peut maintenant survivre.
Un autre exemple :
l'exemple du virus de la grippe.
Vous savez que virus de la grippe
fait chaque année des épidémies.
On est encore en plein
dans l'épidémie de cet hiver.
Et ce virus fait des épidémies,
fait des maladies, peu de morts
et les personnes survivent
à cette épidémie, guérissent.
Ils guérissent parce qu'ils produisent,
entre autres, des anticorps
qui viennent neutraliser
l'infection virale.
Donc la personne survit, a des anticorps.
L'année suivante, le virus revient
et les conditions ont changé
parce que dans la population,
il y a des gens qui ont des anticorps
et ces anticorps font une barrière
à la multiplication virale
si bien que le virus est inhibé
dans sa propagation dans la population.
Mais parmi la population virale,
il y a ce variant, ce mutant,
qui a acquis une mutation
qui lui permet d'échapper
à la neutralisation par les anticorps
parce qu'il échappe à la liaison
de ces anticorps sur le virus.
Et ce variant minoritaire
l'année précédente
devient majoritaire et est responsable
de l'épidémie de l'année suivante.
Et l'année suivante, encore,
ce variant ayant fait des anticorps
au cours de son épidémie,
on va trouver un troisième variant
qui va prendre la place du virus
et qui explique qu'année après année,
les épidémies de grippe
peuvent se [perpétuer].
Voilà deux exemples qui vous montrent
le pouvoir d'adaptation du virus.
Revenons au « penser virus » ;
revenons à une propriété essentielle
que les virus ont dû développer
pour pouvoir survivre.
Et quelque chose
qui paraît assez intuitif,
c'est que le virus n'a pas intérêt
à détruire l'hôte,
détruire complètement l'hôte
nécessaire à sa survie.
Effectivement, si un virus tue
toutes les zones nécessaires à sa survie,
ce virus a toutes les chances
de disparaître avec son hôte.
C'est un peu moins intuitif
que le virus n'a même pas intérêt
à rendre l'hôte qu'il infecte malade.
Parce que cet hôte malade
peut ne pas représenter un hôte
qui a suffisamment d'énergie à mettre
à disposition de la multiplication virale.
Et on en arrive à se dire que, là,
le virus a le plus de chance de survie
s'il réussit à faire son infection
et sa propagation
dans des hôtes dans lesquels
il ne produit aucun effet délétère.
Est-ce que c'est vrai
ou c'est juste de la théorie ?
C'est vrai !
Il y a les virus chez l'homme,
des virus herpétiques -
bouton de fièvre, varicelle -
des virus qui infectent
80% de la population mondiale.
Ces 80 % de la population mondiale,
la plupart ne savent même pas
qu'ils sont infectés.
D'autant que ces virus infectent
les individus en bas âge
et passent toute la vie de l'individu
avec lui dans son organisme.
Un autre exemple est le virus SIV
chez les chimpanzés.
SIV est le précurseur du virus HIV
chez l'homme.
Il a passé du monde chimpanzé
au monde homme.
Mais chez les chimpanzés, ce virus
ne donne aucun symptôme.
C'est la même chose pour le virus Ebola.
Le virus Ebola dans son hôte naturel,
qui est une espèce de chauve-souris,
ne provoque aucun symptôme
et il a fallu beaucoup de temps
pour trouver cet hôte naturel,
tellement il avait peu d'effet
sur cette espèce.
Donc, en fin de compte,
si la période d'adaptation à l'hôte,
si les conditions ne changent pas le même
hôte pendant suffisamment longtemps,
le virus va évoluer pour se multiplier
en parfait entendement avec son hôte.
La situation change un peu lorsque
cet équilibre avec l'hôte a été établi,
et que pour une raison due au hasard,
vraisemblablement,
ce virus change d'espèce et par exemple
passe de la volaille à l'homme.
A ce moment-là,
il y a incertitude sur le virus
qui va réussir à émerger
de ce changement drastique.
Et alors il y a une incertitude
au sujet de ce qui va arriver
et il y a un danger potentiel.
Et là il y a une prise de risque,
il y a la nécessité de comprendre
ce qu'il va se passer
pour essayer de l'anticiper.
Donc en résumé, penser virus,
c'est comprendre le monde viral,
comprendre que les populations virales
sont d'une grande hétérogénéité,
que cette hétérogénéité est garante
de sa faculté d'adaptation
et qu'elle est sous sélection permanente
pour faire surgir le mieux adapté
et dans sa population hétérogène
contient toutes les solutions
pour des changements de conditions.
Voilà, j'en ai fini.
Je vous remercie en vous signalant
que j'anime un blog
qui est viropourtous.ch
qui est destiné au grand public
et je vous invite à aller
consulter les articles
où vous trouverez ce genre d'informations
et bien d'autres.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)